all right Ivy ivy
where you from urgency where'd you grow
up Pasadena Pasadena and tell me about
your childhood had both your parents
when you were kid no I never knew my dad
I go with my mom I was the last of five
and I was kind of only when I really
stay with her anyway
how was your childhood it was it was
cool my mom kept me out of like the
drummer the limelight until I was like
16 and I started doing my own thing yeah
my brothers and sisters they they was
already into the street life and she had
basically sent them away at a young age
because she had her first at 15 so she
couldn't take care of a lot of us so in
York you looked home at what age huh you
left home at what age I left home at 16
16 yeah and where'd you go I met a duel
and I went to the streets and I just
started making money and the guy you met
was was he - yeah and so you would work
Figueroa or Pasadena or what Sapulpa it
was my first strike yeah you remember
your first time picking up the guy
picking you up I got in a police car at
my first time first ever I got in the
police car I wasn't really scared for
some reason I wasn't scared at all I
heard any speaker go off and I just was
like what the heck and I didn't give me
a bit in arresting or anything and after
that I just I kept going I got stopped
after that
and how much money were you making about
three to five hundred a night how old do
you know I'm Clooney you're 20
so you've enjoyed this a few years you
make are you making more money now yeah
yeah well I know what do you make it
right now
I like eight hundred at the most I don't
know where do with yeah have you had
some bad experiences oh yeah yeah
sometimes these guys are crazy right
oh yeah I've gotten thrown out on the
freeway I've gotten hit by cars I've
gotten raped mmm yeah it's crazy stuff
you've been arrested more than more than
that first time more than I can count on
my fingers and toes yeah sorry for a
jail for prostitution most of my cases
are prostitution yeah her drugs are part
of your life oh yeah
yeah I first experienced Jen's when I
was 16 and I just never stopped doing it
and what are using today yeah crystal
night mm-hmm
so the guys that pick you up I'll take
you where hotel or the car in the car
now yeah and your hours you'll work or
typically what all day all day
how late into the night to go to I don't
sleep crystal meth honestly yeah give
kids have a daughter give a daughter are
you raising her so you have yep mouths
mouths to feed and yeah and this money
is something you need to survive right
yeah can you have you considered other
you know a more legitimate way of making
money or most definitely everybody got a
better way to make money yes
what's your addicted to I'm gonna date
to do it do you think your digit I'm
addicted to sweets ever ever that a lot
yeah it's crazy
but what is it about the streets you
think that that does that for people I
don't know honestly I don't know it's
the I think it's I think it's the family
orientation how everybody feels so
connected cuz everybody and judging
nobody you you really not gonna judge
this most most people you come in
contact in the streets is doing worse or
doing the same thing is easy so you
never feel like you you know gotta live
up to anybody's standards you just do
what you got to do a marginal business
are you so working with the tail no no
how long did that last
I stopped myself inches when I was 17
yeah my sister she showed me how to get
money on my own and I used to ride the
train say LA and just walk
how to do walk breathing the most
misunderstood thing about this lifestyle
like people that don't do it they don't
understand it what do you think they
don't understand they don't understand
the pain I don't know because you don't
do it
everybody got pain but I feel like it's
a different type of pain the streets is
a whole different type of pain cuz it's
levels to the streets just like it's
levels to live in a regular life you
know if it's a different type of pain
knowing alive I understand it because
it's a pain that you cannot you're not
supposed to feel it but you feel it it's
different it's it hurts
but it's like you got to force yourself
to be numb to it are you saving money
you are
how do you think working as a prostitute
for the last three four years has has
changed you
it ain't changing hasn't it I just I do
the same thing every day I don't change
it takes a special personality for
somebody to do this and survive right
not ever not any girl to do this yeah
everyone can do it you think yeah I do I
think everyone can do it everyone's not
gonna be able to stick with it though
that's not easy what advice would you
give to a young girl who's considering
doing something like this get to know
yourself it's not worth it's definitely
not worth it you get to know yourself
and love yourself and be able to look
yourself in the mirror because once you
get out here you can't you can't change
or you know everything you do is gonna
be your fault you know and you're gonna
need something like people say like you
don't have to do drugs when you're out
there you know it comes with it and once
you out there and you got a you know
stay up or you gonna want it you gonna
need something to stimulate you and
think it makes it harder for you to look
in the mirror and see yourself so so
young girls that you know might meet a
guy or a girl who tells him about this
lifestyle it's not it is a chat do you
feel like the pimp that brought you in
early on might have led you into this
then you may have avoided it if he had
mm I wouldn't say it was him because I
was subject to it I was shown it I knew
about it I just it just took like a man
because I that's why I was attracted to
I was a game girl it took him too
you know but I knew without if it wasn't
him I wouldn't still did this order and
got addicted to it does your family know
you're doing this yeah what's their
reaction they don't like it but I mom
knew very well she first found out I was
in sheets my sister called her and told
her to come get me and she's just like
what do you want me to do if she hung up
so I always felt like I could just do
what I wanted to do my mom never put a
leash on me so I found these kind of
like don't you got to do or any of your
brothers sisters doing something similar
all of them they're all incarcerated
you're the only one that's not yeah
does this life get you down sometimes
you get depressed uh yeah of course but
what about it is is the most like
unsettling part of it just the the
danger or um no matter how many years
I've been prostituting every day when I
step out onto the street I'm always
nervous I always get nervous cuz you
never know who get in a car waiting and
so that that's the most unsettling part
for me
you never know no matter how tough you
are no matter how much drugs you own
it's I always get nervous yeah yeah you
lose your life yeah you constantly gotta
be in you know fight-or-flight mode use
your intuition mmm and I always got to
cut back to my daughter started thinking
about that every time I step out I
always tell myself I'm coming back home
to my daughter Turner well I they thank
you so much for sharing your story thank
you good luck with with your daughter
and wherever your life goes from here
you're still very young
yeah you can do a lot of different
things from here thank you thank you
you